yeah isn't that nice you sit down early
in the morning
play some entertaining chess and you get
you know who okay let's see what is
coming up next this line again okay can
also do that I think I'm probably going
to go geez three then huh yeah we had
some some games in this in this line now
I can try you six
I have tried that before I think not
quite sure Knight c3 we also had some
games so we should be fine yeah of
course that's a decent idea yeah you can
go f6 in this position hmm no also
screen a5 the move looks a bit strange
honestly you have it maybe still how bad
can it be
I think I have seen f6 in this position
okay it's so going to take and then
castle
yeah White has a bit more activity
[Music]
interesting I probably he will play the
Bishop back anyway
to d3 or something I just wonder how to
best develop
let's go Bishop d7 I'm not entirely
convinced
okay I go a six and just be five Nixie
we go back yeah yeah I was thinking B
five if I just wonder if they ever have
something else but this is kind of kind
of fits into it
the b-pawn is also hanging so I expect
something something with d5 and c4 maybe
d5 right away no not t5 right away what
is this move doing I don't know
looking at the b6 square maybe not
exactly what I expected which would seem
I was just thinking 97 here isn't that
okay for me okay no move now that seems
okay check
queen bee seven or something is he
winning a pawn
generous idea
hmm yeah that's a bit better knowing
their queen a4 maybe was having having a
look at the rook it's a bit of a loose
smooth looks a bit loose
evam losing this pawn that's not
necessarily all that other terrible 1095
probably
okay with the green capture he's not
checking anything there anymore so I
know I have can just move the Queen for
example
Quincy - let's receive one unfortunately
this was a move that ahead
there was one of my my ideas okay so
then let's play this bloody ending
what should you never back rangas is
always weak him unfortunately time
morning that's the second problem
[Music]
hmm I could have taken here for opposite
colored bishops I mean maybe do that the
40 seconds is the biggest biggest issue
the position is of course worse for me
but we know how how it works against
India White has order I mean it's not
playing or time he just is better you 45
probably
j-jim this position is probably a draw
but 20 seconds
Jim twelve seconds is in actually has
probably losing of it okay didn't really
met him
oh is it a draw I might have a fortress
him clean these things as a fortress
yeah Kim I just spent far too much time
sitting in this in this position yeah I
was I was just too worried probably
because like it's never going to be
worse here anyway like not seriously
worse check it should just play cricket
yeah I mean so I know he took this okay
I can actually be better with 93 but
[Music]
okay I did I just saw that this is kind
of okay but I spent too much time going
into this I think here blacks drawing
chances are still fairly good okay you
as usual didn't care all that much
I'm trying for something because he knew
the time will work for him
jeong-ja I would like to understand a
bit how that position came came came
about I think here I can also play a six
but I don't think that can you fight us
all that terrible this is I am certainly
okay ninety-five is a funny idea yeah I
saw these ideas with the discovery but
what I did not see is that yeah I can
actually take ha that it makes it pretty
strong actually if White has to play
this then I'm very okay okay does it
tell you that I completely missed and
here I was expecting d5 which is
stronger can okay
Queen D H is also a good news just hmm
not caring all that much about the pawn
I have this and oops I have this and
play against the pawn yeah something
like that yeah I still have those odd
games way I tend to just against him
take far too long because you kind of
vary it yeah getting into this kind of
slightly worse ending that he will play
forever and ever and so on and yeah then
at the end I get there but after having
pondered about whatever for for much too
long while you probably won't lose if
you just play play quickly okay thanks
for watching